pas
[Musique]
ce jour-là l'activité n'était pas
commune à l'auberge du bel air
marie-andrée et pierre se prépare pour
participer à leur premier salon
international de l'agriculture à paris
déjà montré la beauté de la réunion et
principalement la beauté de notre site
je pense qu'on est quand même
privilégiée d'habiter un site pareil
c'est une façon aussi de ramener la
réunion une petite partie de la réunion
en métropole
ici à la ferme du bel-air donc on
transforme un peu de tout bien sûr la
viande de la volaille principalement et
aussi des fruits et légumes beaucoup de
achats et des confitures le meilleur du
curcuma et à la réunion
[Musique]
et quelques jours plus tard la
température n'est pas la même nous les
retrouvons dans la foule des exposants
être pas facile de faire sa place dans
cet événement international qui compte
plus de six cent soixante quinze mille
visiteurs avec 22 pays représentés les
23 exposants réunionnais le savent le
département chef de file de l'autorité
agricole de lille met les petits plats
dans les grands pour une démarche
collaborative
alors quand c'est une première
l'ambition est grande
c'est présenter nos produits nous faire
connaître montrer qu'on a des capacités
des compétences dans l'océan indien a
créé un produit de qualité à haute
valeur ajoutée parce que nous avions
besoin et nous devons vivre de notre
travail
maintenant nos plantes sont dans des
amphis êtes on a réussi à mettre les
plantes médicinales de ville en format
infusettes pour doser pour un litre soit
le premier salon le premier le premier
comme massa dès que je prends là dessus
de bien vendre
de rentrer à la réunion un nouveau
l'agencé et lorsque parisse et vas y que
la foule intègre les stands la réunion
montre son plus beau visage à heureux
bien sûr comme tous les exposants il
sort ici aux phrases des expositions et
et c'est vrai que quand on rentre dans
ce hall 5.1
c'est toute la réunion qu'on voit
puisque notre stand est magnifique et
nous exposant aux envies nos exposants
sont déterminés et je ne peux que leur
souhaiter un excellent salon de
l'agriculture 2010 9 avec bien sûr
réussite à la clé et surtout une
renommée de la réunion a porté à travers
le monde
pendant une semaine des milliers de
visiteurs sont attendus dans le hall 5
une certitude les ambassadeurs de
l'agriculture pays sont frais